in the videos on on massive stars and on
black holes we learned that if the
remnant of a star of a massive star is
massive enough the gravitational
contraction the gravitational force will
be stronger than even the electron
degeneracy pressure even stronger than
the neutron degeneracy pressure even
stronger than the quark degeneracy
pressure and everything would collapse
into a point into a point and we called
these points black holes black holes and
we learned there's an event horizon
around these black holes and if anything
gets closer or goes within the boundary
of that event horizon there's no way
that can ever escape from the black hole
all it can do is get closer and closer
to the black hole and that includes
light and that's why it's called a black
hole so even though all of the mass is
at the central point this entire area or
the entire surface of the event horizon
this entire surface of the event horizon
I'll do it in purple because it's
supposed to be black this entire thing
will appear black it will emit it will
emit no light now though these type of
black holes that we describe would call
those stellar black holes stellar
stellar black holes and that's because
they're formed from collapsing massive
stars and the largest stellar black
holes that we've observed are on the
order of 33 solar masses give or take 33
solar masses so very massive to begin
with let's just be clear and this is
what the remnant of the star has to be
so a lot more of the original stars mass
might have been pushed off in supernovae
I'm Laura love supernova now there's
another class of black holes here and
these are somewhat mysterious and
they're called supermassive black holes
super supermassive black holes and to
some degree the word super isn't big
enough supermassive black holes because
they're just they're not just a little
bit more massive than stellar stellar
black holes there are a lot more massive
they're on the order of hundreds of
thousands hundreds of thousands
to billions to billions billions of
solar masses a hundred thousands to
billions times the mass of our Sun solar
masses and what's interesting about
these other than the fact that they are
super huge is that there doesn't seem to
be black holes in between or at least we
haven't observed black holes in between
weave up the largest stellar black holes
33 solar masses and then there are these
supermassive black holes that we think
exists and that we think they mean ly
exist in the Centers of galaxies and we
think most if not all centers of
galaxies actually have one of these
supermassive black holes but it's kind
of an interesting question if all black
holes were formed from collapsing stars
wouldn't we see things in between so one
theory of how these really massive black
holes form is that you have a regular
stellar black hole in an area that has a
lot of matter that it can accrete around
it so let's imagine you have a regular
so I'll draw thee this is the event
horizon around it the actual black hole
is going to be in the center of a toward
the mass of the black hole will be in
the center of it and then over time you
just have you have just more and more
mass just falling into this black hole
just more and more stuff just keeps
falling into this black hole and then it
just keeps growing and then it just
keeps growing and so this could be a
plausible reason or at least the mass in
the center keeps growing until the event
horizon will also keep growing in radius
now this is a plausible explanation
based on our current understanding but
the reason why this one doesn't gel that
well is you would if this was the
explanation for supermassive black holes
you would explain you expect to see more
black holes in between maybe black holes
with a hundred solar masses or a
thousand solar masses or ten thousand
solar masses but we're not seeing those
right now we just see the stellar black
holes and we see the supermassive black
holes so another possible explanation
this is where my my inclinations lean
towards this one because it kind of
explains the gap is that these
supermassive black holes actually formed
shortly after the Big Bang that these
are primordial black holes these are
very these started near the beginning of
our universe primordial primordial black
hole
now remember what do you need to have a
black hole you need to have an amazingly
dense amount of matter or a dense amount
of mass if you have a lot of mass in a
very small volume then their
gravitational pull will pull them closer
and closer to closer together and
they'll able to bill be able to overcome
all of the the electron degeneracy
pressure is and the neutron degeneracy
pressures and the court degenerative
pressures to really cool to really
collapse into what we think is a single
point I want to be clear here too we
don't know it's a single point we've
never gone into the center of a black
hole just the mathematics of the black
holes or at least as we understand it
right now have everything colliding into
a single point where the math starts to
break down so we're really not sure what
happens at that at that very small
center point but needless to say it will
be an unbelievably may be infinite may
be almost infinitely dense point in
space or dense amount of matter and the
reason why I kind of favored this
primordial black hole and why this would
make sense is right after the formation
of the universe all of the matter was in
the universe was in a much denser space
because the universe was smaller so
let's say that this is right after the
Big Bang some period of time after the
Big Bang now what we've talked about
before when we talked about cosmic
background radiation is at that point
the universe was relatively uniform it
was super super dense but it was
relatively uniform so you know a
universe like this there's no reason why
anything would collapse into black holes
because if you look at a point here sure
there's a ton of mass very close to it
but it's very close to it in every
direction so it would be pulled the
gravitational force would be the same in
every direction if it was completely
uniform but if you go shortly after the
Big Bang maybe because of slight quantum
fluctuation effects it becomes slightly
non-uniform so let's say it become
slightly non-uniform but it still is
unbelievably dense so let's say it looks
something like this where you have areas
that are denser and but it's it's
slightly slightly non-uniform but
extremely dense extremely dense so here
all of a sudden you have the type of
densities necessary for a black hole and
where you have
where you have higher densities where
it's less uniform here all of a sudden
you will have inward force the the
gravitational pull from things outside
of this area we're going to be less than
the gravitational pull towards those
area and the more things and the more
things get pulled towards it the more
the less uniform it's going to get so
you can imagine in that primordial
universe at very shortly after the Big
Bang when things were very dense and
closely packed together you we may we
may have had the conditions where these
supermassive black holes could have
formed where we had so much mass in such
a small volume and it was just not
uniform enough so that you can kind of
have the snowballing effect so that more
and more mass would collect would
collect into into these supermassive the
supermassive black holes that are
hundreds of thousands to billions of
times the mass of the Sun and this is
maybe didn't even more interesting part
those black holes would become the
Centers of future galaxies so things
that so you have these black holes
forming these supermassive black holes
forming and then as not everything would
go into a black hole only if it didn't
have a lot of if it didn't have a lot of
angular velocity then it might go into
the black hole but if it's going past it
fast enough it'll just start going in
orbit around the black hole and so you
could imagine that this is how the early
galaxies or even our galaxies formed and
so you might be wondering well what
about the galaxies at the center of the
Milky Way or so what about the black
hole at the center of the Milky Way and
we think there is one we think there is
one because we've observed stars
orbiting very quickly around something
at the center of at the center of the
universe I start at the center of our
Milky Way want to be very clear not at
the center of the universe and the only
plausible explanation for it it it
orbiting so quickly around something is
that it has to have a density of either
a black hole or something that will
eventually turn into a black hole and
when you do the math for the middle of
our galaxy the center of the Milky Way
our supermassive black hole is on the
order of four million times the mass
times the mass of the Sun so hopefully
that gives you a little bit of food for
thought there aren't just only stellar
collapse
coal's or maybe there are and somehow
they grow into supermassive black holes
and that everything in between we just
can't observe or that they really are a
different class of black holes or
actually form different ways maybe they
formed near the beginning of the actual
universe when things just the the
density of things was a little on
uniform things condensed into each other
we're going to talk about in the next
video is how these supermassive black
holes can generate can help generate
unbelievable sources of radiation even
though the black holes themselves aren't
emitting them and those are going to be
quasars